and so as we look at kind of what's
transpired obviously there's the virus
and you know people I think will blame a
lot of kind of the economic issue on
that but that's not the full story so
maybe kind of walk us through how have
we gotten from that roaring period to
now you know double digit losses in a
matter of months and really one month
and the stock market's commodities
falling and kind of this deflationary
liquidity crisis yeah look it's it is
again that that giant question for all
of us to think about and it's why you
know Congress is is pulling out all the
stops and pulling out the giant bazookas
with with a couple trillion and I love
how we throw the T word around right I
mean in the 30s it was Millions
and then in the 60s 50 60s it was it was
billions and and then in in the 2000s it
was hundreds of billions and and now
we're talking trillions and a trillion
just one trillion forget two or six or
whatever the number is but just one
trillion is a dollar every second for
thirty one thousand seven hundred and
ten years I mean that's just a giant
number and so Congress is freaking out
the Fed is freaking out you know they
put out four trillion now that's a
headline number they've offered four
trillion of support no one's actually
borrowing that money I think the day
they put out the trillion dollar repo
line only 17 billion got pulled by the
big hedge funds and don't let's let's
let's be very clear and transparent
about this the Fed action was to
backstop these quasi financial
institutions that while the banks don't
need a bailout this time because they've
been restricted because of dodd-frank
and how levered they could get there are
no such restrictions on the big hedge
funds and the prop trading desks off
Wall Street so they have huge leverage
you know arguably 10 15 20 times and
some of them were gone right they were
just done and I still think there's
gonna be some bodies that float to the
surface here over the next couple weeks
but yeah all that money is really
interesting about media about the
leverage I want to go a little bit
deeper on that because two things here
so one is we've seen a couple of firms
who haven't been able to meet margin
calls kind of raise their hand and have
to alert people to that but I don't
think people really understand this
whole repo market and I'm kind of
bailing out of the hedge funds maybe
just explain that a little bit more uh
so kind of what's happening there and
how the hell is it hedge funds on the
other side of that yeah look it's a
really interesting phenomenon right
which is leverage in and of itself it's
not a bad thing right many of us use
leverage in our lives although I guess
it's getting less common as less people
own homes but anyone who owns a home
uses a lot of leverage right they put
20% down or or less you know some FHA
loans are 3% down or 2% down so you're
using a lot of leverage to to buy
physical assets and it's not different
in the banking and finance world like a
bank takes a deposit and they hold a
portion of it they lend out 90 some odd
percent of it fractional reserve banking
somebody else deposits that 90 cents
then they keep another nine cents they
lend out 81 cents and so you get this
rehypothecation you get this building up
of leverage in the system and all those
loans that went to quasi financial
institutions or hedge funds a lot of
them started doing trades around fixed
income markets that that historically
they wouldn't have done because there
was plenty to do in equity markets but
equity valuations got really high and
they would normally do things like
arbitrage merger arbitrage or
convertible bond arbitrage but in a zerp
world in a zero interest rate world
arbitrage is really hard you think about
it if you're a dollar long and a dollar
short
your dollar sits in cash in the old days
you made six seven percent just on your
cash then you made money on your long
you made money on your short and you
were levered so making double-digit
returns as a hedge fund was child's play
now you had to have some ski
but it really was in the heart in a zerp
world you're not making any money on
your cash you actually have to pay to
borrow so you have no short interest
rebate where you were making money
you're actually paying to borrow so
you're in the hole alpha gets crammed
down because there's so many firms
competing for the same ideas because
again in the old days of investing it
was about access to information right
not not illegal information but access
to information if you could get
information faster if you could get
information that other people didn't
have then you had a huge advantage well
suddenly with the advent of Bloomberg
and other resources information became
ubiquitous and once information is
ubiquitous access isn't really that
valuable then it became about processing
did you have computers that allows you
to process information faster or model
faster or build you know ideas faster
and the problem is then everyone got
fast computers so that went away so then
it became about synthesis like who could
synthesize and who could take all the
disparate information and information
became a commodity again information
became ubiquitous everyone had the same
information it was in real time you had
actually regulations like reg FD as my
friend in Boston calls it regulation
fecund disaster that disallowed people
from doing their job which would be to
build relationships with corporate ceos
and cfos and be able to ask them really
hard questions and now the answer has to
be no I can't tell you that I got to
release the information to everybody so
it all became about synthesis and
understanding what's not important and
what is important so all this comes down
to the fact that these funds started
doing some of the things that the
infamous long term capital management
did things like basis trading or things
like convergence trading and let's just
talk about a convergence trade for a
second so if you take a 30-year bond we
know one thing with certainty in 365
days it will be a 29 year bond
and then four it will no longer be
what's called on the run
meaning the popular Treasury for hedging
and investment purposes so with absolute
certainty in 365 days it's a 29 year
bond no longer a 30-year bond now a
30-year bond trades more expensive than
a 29 year bond even though they're
basically the same bond but you can make
five basis points well five basis points
isn't a lot but since it's a guaranteed
event uh-huh there's no risk well
there's no risk if you can hold the
trade for 365 days but let's say you put
on a five basis point rate and you put a
hundred times leverage on it and let's
say there's some dislocation in the
market and that five basis points spread
goes to ten basis points you've now lost
everything you get a margin call and
you're forced to liquidate even though
you know with absolute certainty if you
could just hold the trade so that was
one type of thing that started to blow
up but then there are these other bonds
that people were buying in the hedge
fund space where there's there's what's
called market to market risk which is if
you think about liquid tradable senior
debt you know bank loans senior secured
loans you know investment grade bonds
they should trade at par right you're
gonna get your money back they shouldn't
trade at a discount ah but wait a second
if there's a liquidity crisis if there's
a period or people get afraid and that's
where Kovac comes in kovat becomes a
stimulus a prick to the bubble it's not
the bubble itself but it's the pin to
the bubble and suddenly people are
fighting for liquidity and they get a
margin call on their equities well when
you get a margin call you're not able to
sell what you want to sell you sell what
you have to sell and so some of these
bonds that were very very safe suddenly
gapped down so you had you know senior
secured bonds that suddenly should trade
at 99 or 100 suddenly trading at 90 well
if you
those cash no big deal oh but if I owned
them with ten times leverage I just lost
all my equity so these things start
unwinding and you saw lqd for example
the the ETF for investment grade bonds
fell seven percent in three days it's
never fallen seven percent ever it
shouldn't fall seven percent because
it's investment grade bonds and those
bonds most of them are gonna be money
good ah unless and we'll talk about more
that we'll talk more about this later
unless the response to the virus in
shutting down global economic activity
leads to actual defaults in those
investment grade bonds because they
borrowed too much money they didn't
spend enough on R&D they didn't save for
a rainy day and they don't get enough
bailout money well that's a it's a
long-winded way of saying funds were
doing things that normally appeared to
have low risk but a Black Swan event
which wasn't necessarily the virus
itself the virus is a bad thing and we
can argue how bad it is and you know if
you look at the number of people who've
passed away from influenza this year's
23,000 in the US and the kovat is you
know had eight hundred and twenty guess
which one is worse I argue 23,000 is
worse than 820 but maybe a 1020 is going
to grow and so we can have that debate
all day long but the key is it's not the
virus it's the response and the drop in
economic activity the drop of cash flows
and the threat of what seemed like a
very very safe thing suddenly becomes
unsafe